IS WILLING OR NOT WILLING TO DO.
>> CNN'S MJ LEE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> NOW TO UKRAINE, WHERE CNN
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY EDITOR
NICK PATON WALSH IS ON THE HEELS
OF UKRAINIAN FORCES AS THEY PUSH
BACK RUSSIAN TROOPS IN A TRULY
REMARKABLE MILITARY OFFENSIVE
RECLAIMING AND LIBERATING LARGE
REGIONS OF THEIR COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: JUST AHEAD IS
RUSSIA IN RETREAT.
THE ROAD CUT BY A BRIDGE BLOWN
FOUR DAYS AGO AS THEY FLED.
A LIGHTNING UKRAINIAN ADVANCE
ALONG THE RIVER BANK HERE.
RUSSIAN JETS FIRING BACK.
KYIV'S FORCES, AGAIN, MOVING
AROUND AN ENEMY STUCK IN PARK
AND REVERSE.
LEFT IN RUSSIA'S WAKE, THIS
OLDER ANTI-AIRCRAFT SYSTEM,
STILL WORKING, WE'RE TOLD, AND
THE TATTY SIGNS OF HOW THEY
LIVED IN THE OPEN.
HE SAID THEY DIDN'T FIND ANY
BODIES HERE.
THEY JUST RAN AND LEFT IT.
A RUSH TO GATHER THE HARVEST.
SINCE MARCH, THE RUSSIANS MOVED
IN NEXT DOOR.
UNTIL MONDAY WHEN THEY SEEMED TO
HAVE DITCHED EVEN THEIR CLOTHES.
THE AIR IS ONLY SLIGHTLY FREER
NOW, BUT STILL HERE, THEY SPENT
LAST NIGHT UNDER GROUND.
AT NIGHT, IT'S HARDEST, HE SAYS.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW WHO'S
SHOOTING WHERE.
WE BROUGHT OUR FOOD DOWN HERE SO
IT DOESN'T GET TORCHED.
MOST OF HIS WIFE'S FAMILY LIVE
IN RUSSIA, BUT HERE, THE
RUSSIANS CAME TO LIVE NEXT DOOR
TO THEM, ONE NIGHT, DRUNK.
ONE CAME OUT AND SAID, WHO ARE
YOU, WAVING HIS GUN AT US, SHE
SAYS.
HE WAS DRUNK.
IT WAS PRETTY DANGEROUS, ADDS
VLADIMIR.
THEY ARE LITERALLY IN THE CROSS
H OF FIRE HERE.
UNLESS YOU KNOW THE LONGER YOU
LIVE, SHE SAYS, UNDER THE TREES,
WORRIED ABOUT DRONES.
WE LIVED A GOOD LIFE, NEVER
TOUCHED ANYONE.
ALL ALONG THE ROAD, THE DETRIETS
OF A FAILING EMPIRE ON THE RUN.
ON SUNDAY, THEY TOOK 50
PRISONERS, INCLUDING NEWLY
MOBILIZED CONSCRIPTS.
THIS SOLDIER'S HOME IS LITERALLY
IN SIGHT, IN OCCUPIED LAND, SO
HE DOESN'T SHOW HIS FACE.
YOUR HOUSE IS JUST OVER THERE.
THERE'S NO GREATER MOTIVATION,
HE SAYS.
WE DIDN'T ASK THEM TO COME HERE.
HOME.
EVERYONE HOME.
IT IS OUR LAND.
>> MAMA.
>> Reporter: FOR OTHERS, HOME IS
ALMOST A TRAP.
>> MAMA.
>> Reporter: LUBA IS STUCK HERE
AS HER 92-YEAR-OLD MOTHER CAN'T
WALK.
SHE'S HIDDEN UNDER THE BEDDING.
THEY HAVE ONLY MILK AND BISCUITS
TO EAT.
AND WHEN THERE'S SHELLING,
THERE'S NO BASEMENT.
SO, LUBA JUST LIES ON TOP OF
MAMA.
IMAGINE NOT BEING ABLE TO MOVE
WHEN THE GROUND IS SHAKING.
[ SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH ]
>> Reporter: SHE COVERS HER
AGAIN SO SHE DOESN'T FALL OUT OF
BED WHEN SHE GOES OUT.
OUTSIDE, THE HIGHWAY IS BUSY.
HOWEVER FAST UKRAINE MOVES
THROUGH HERE, NOTHING CAN BE
UNDONE OR BRING THE OLD SILENCE
BACK.
WOLF, IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
IN THE TALK OF ALL THESE NUCLEAR
THREATS EXACTLY HOW POORLY
RUSSIA'S CONVENTIONAL MILITARY
ARE DOING ON THE GROUND DAY BY
DAY.
THEY BARELY HAD BOTTLES OF
WATER, BARELY HAD FOOD, BARELY
HAD SPONGE MATS TO SLEEP UPON,
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE EFFECTIVENESS OR THE
WILLINGNESS TO USES OF RUSSIA'S
MOST COMPLICATED, MOST DEADLY
THREAT, WOLF.
>> CNN'S NICK PATON WALSH IN THE
WAR ZONE FOR US.
NICK, BE CAREFUL OVER THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS WITH
THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, JOHN
BRENNAN.
HIS BOOK IS
ENTITLED, "UNDAUNTED: MY FIGHT
AGAINST AMERICA'S ENEMIES AT
HOME AND ABROAD."
IT'S NOW OUT, BY THE WAY, IN
PAPERBACK AS WELL.
DIRECTOR BRENNAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
LET'S START WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S VERY STARK WARNING.
IS HE RIGHT THAT PUTIN IS
RAISING THE STAKES, POTENTIALLY,
OF NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON?
>> WELL, WOLF, AS WAS JUST
REPORTED, IT'S CLEAR THAT RUSSIA
HAS SUFFERED VERY MAJOR SETBACKS
ON THE BATTLE FIELD, AND THE
UKRAINIAN ARE ON A ROLL, AND
WHILE IT'S GOOD NEWS, THERE'S
ALSO SOME WORRISOME CONSEQUENCES
AND IMPLICATIONS OF THAT, WHICH
IS THAT PUTIN HAS TO FIND WAYS
TO RAISE FORTUNES ON THE BATTLE
FIELD, WHICH HAS RAISED THE
SPECTER THAT HE MIGHT OPT TO USE
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN SOME
MANNER.
IT WOULD BE A WAY TO SEND A
SMALL THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO
RELENT.
SO, I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHO
HAS BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR RUSSIA'S USE
OF THESE TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS RAISED HIS CONCERNS
PUBLICLY LAST NIGHT AT DINNER,
AND SO THEREFORE I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING THAT NOT ONLY
PRESIDENT BIDEN BUT OTHERS ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT TO DO IN
RESPONSE IF, INDEED, PUTIN
DECIDES TO GO DOWN THAT TACTICAL
NUCLEAR ROUTE.
>> MULTIPLE OFFICIALS, DIRECTOR
BRENNAN, HAVE CAUTIONED THAT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID LAST
NIGHT ISN'T BASED ON ANY NEW
INTELLIGENCE, SO DO THESE
POTENTIALLY OFF-THE-CUFF REMARKS
BY THE PRESIDENT PLAY INTO
PUTIN'S HANDS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
WAR, NUMBER OF MONTHS AGO, WE
THOUGHT THAT THE CHANCES OF IT
GOING NUCLEAR WERE VERY, VERY
LOW.
BUT I TO THINK OVER THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS, AGAIN, GIVEN THESE
SETBACKS THAT RUSSIA HAS, I
THINK PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT
IT AND WORRYING ABOUT IT MORE
SERIOUSLY, SO THEREFORE, I THINK
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS DOING IS
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A VERY
DANGEROUS SITUATION, AND WHILE I
DON'T THINK WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF
ARMAGEDDON, I DON'T THINK THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN REALLY MEANT
THAT EITHER.
I THINK WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
THAT THIS COULD ENTER SOME TYPE
OF STAGE WHERE THE USE OF
NUCLEAR -- TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS NOT ALL THAT
UNTHINKABLE.
>> YEAH, IT'S A HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE THOUGHT, EVEN TO THINK
ABOUT THAT.
CLEARLY IT'S ON THE MIND OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I ALSO WANT TO GET YOUR ANALYSIS
ON NORTH KOREA RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO YOU READ THIS LATEST
FLURRY OF MISSILE LAUNCHES BY
NORTH KOREA, BEYOND TRYING TO
GAIN THE WORLD'S ATTENTION?
IS THIS A SIGN NORTH KOREA IS
SERIOUSLY ADVANCING RIGHT NOW
ITS OWN MILITARY CAPABILITIES?
>> WELL, WE KNOW THAT NORTH
KOREA HAS NUCLEAR WARHEADS, AND
IT HAS DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
THESE DIFFERENT TYPES OF MISSILE
SYSTEMS, SHORT, MEDIUM, AND
INTERCONTINENTAL.
AND SO IT CONTINUES TO REFINE
THE WEAPONIZATION, MEANING, THE
MATCHING OF THOSE WARHEADS WITH
THESE BALLISTIC MISSILES, AND SO
BY TESTING IT, I THINK IT WANTS
TO GAIN GREATER CONFIDENCE THAT
SHOULD IT CHOOSE TO GO THAT
ROUTE, IT WILL BE ABLE TO CARRY
OUT A STRIKE AS IT WANTS.
AND SO, I THINK WE CAN NEVER
IGNORE NORTH KOREA'S MILITARY
DEVELOPMENTS, BECAUSE IT DOES
POSE A THREAT TO THE ENTIRE EAST
ASIA REGION AND TO THE UNITED
STATES ITSELF.
>> BY ALL ACCOUNTS, DIRECTOR
BRENNAN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS BRACING FOR
THE POSSIBILITY THAT KIM JONG UN
COULD LAUNCH NORTH KOREA'S
SEVENTH NUCLEAR TEST.
WHAT LEVERS DOES THE U.S. HAVE
RIGHT NOW TO TRY AND TAMP DOWN
THIS INCREASING AGGRESSION?
THE TENSION IS VERY, VERY
INTENSE RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL, AS YOU KNOW, NORTH
KOREA IS UNDER NUMEROUS AND VERY
MAJOR SANCTIONS, AND SO
THEREFORE, I THINK WHAT THE
UNITED STATES IS DOING, AS IT'S
BEEN CONDUCTING US TRAINING
EXERCISES WITH SOUTH KOREA, WILL
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
REGIONAL ALLIES BUT I WOULDN'T
BE SURPRISED IF KIM JONG UN
DECIDES TO CONDUCT ANOTHER
NUCLEAR TEST, BUT QUITE FRANKLY,
THERE'S VERY LITTLE THAT WE CAN
DO TO PREVENT HIM FROM DOING SO.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
ALLIES AND PARTNERS IN THE
REGION TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO BE PREPARED FOR ANY TYPE OF
MILITARY MOVE THAT NORTH KOREA
MIGHT MAKE.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S PLANNING TO
DO ANYTHING AT THIS POINT.
I THINK IT'S JUST TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP ITS MILITARY
CAPABILITIES, SO THEREFORE, I
THINK WE HAVE TO STAY FOCUSED ON
IT, AND ALTHOUGH WE'RE
INTERESTED IN WHAT'S GOING ON,
OBVIOUSLY, IN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA, WE CANNOT NEGLECT OR
IGNORE WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
>> CERTAIN